aunque luchar por la democracia sea
difícil debemos continuar y no rendirnos
nelson wong es uno de los pocos que se
declara pro democracia en las elecciones
legislativas desde la reforma electoral
impuesta por beijing sólo los candidatos
validadas por las autoridades pueden
presentarse en hong kong la mayoría del
campo democrático se ha negado a
someterse a la norma las principales
figuras de la oposición están incluso en
el exilio o en la cárcel
necesitamos a alguien en el consejo
legislativo que luche por la democracia
y por el futuro si no tenemos a alguien
en el consejo no podemos hacer nada
de todos modos el margen de maniobra de
los representantes elegidos será muy
limitado en el consejo legislativo con
la reforma las votaciones del domingo
sólo decidirán 20 escaños de 90 el resto
será designado por grupos de interés que
apoyan las autoridades pero china ese es
el caso de un y siuna miembro de un
partido pro beijing el juego ha cambiado
totalmente para todos e incluso para
nosotros creemos que es muy
representativo y pensamos que todo el
mundo puede opinar en esta votación sin
embargo los hongkoneses parecen no
preocuparse según una encuesta sólo la
mitad de votantes acudirá a las urnas
mientras que en 2016 participó más del
80 por ciento para este politólogo la
falta de interés proviene de la
exclusión de la posición de selección es
que estas elecciones nunca fueron una
forma de que los demócratas siguieran
luchando por un sistema de gobierno más
razonable justo y equitativo
estas elecciones se están utilizando
como una ceremonia para validar las
nuevas normas de beijing para hong kong
será una elección bajo control el
domingo se desplegarán 10.000 agentes de
policía para evitar cualquier altercado